a summer holiday playing war these
Kalashnikov machine guns may not be
loaded with real bullets
but a Tresvant bat camp the boys are
learning how to handle them the kids
here are aged between 10 and 16 it's
Nikita's first time in the military
summer camp the 15 year old is from
nearby Moscow like many of the boys he
wants to try out life as a soldier here
to decide if it's for him you don't feel
like a normal Russian citizen here you
feel like a soldier maybe even in
another country and on a secret mission
it's totally different from normal life
today the boys are swinging into action
to clear a building of terrorists the
instructors say these are current
real-life scenarios from the Russian
Army's operations all the instructors in
the camp have a military background
several are even actively serving
soldiers though the program is open to
girls the camp counselors see it as a
male rite of passage sleep with their
weapons eat with the weapons a man
should always have a weapon with him
it's this job to protect the weak and to
protect women if he doesn't have a
weapon he's not even a man anymore
it was the turning machine ra's vid but
is a private camp and receives no
government funding but the idea matches
the mood in Russia a recent government
survey shows that over 90% of people in
Russia feel patriotic
so far military summer camps are the
exception rather than the rule in Russia
but a recent law promoting patriotic
education in the country praises the
camp's it says they're a good way of
instilling patriotism in young people we
need a strong generation we should all
know how to protect our lone country and
bring up decent kids honestly I feel
like we missed out on bringing up a
whole generation in the 90s after the
fall of the Soviet Union
we are still compensating for that and
that's why the government is also
putting an emphasis on these military
the battalion gathers to review the day
before bed
the organizers insist the camp is about
teamwork and not about patriotism or
preparing a new generation to fight for
Russia patriotism is important to me
it's the love for your home country and
she at the camp and also plays a role if
you have that feeling already it
develops here it's impossible not to be
patriotic here Akita is still deciding
whether the army is for him in the long
run but for some of the boys this camp
has clearly kindled a flame that will be
hard to put out